[Musique]
ok la team écoutez bien ce groupe a
toujours été une famille mais la donne
vient de changer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dominic toretto roule tout
seul tu va tourner le dos à ta famille
je sais que c'est gras mais le lâchez
pas aux civils
c'est notre dernière chance on va
sembler à nouveau notre famille fais pas
ça je te garantis une chose
personne n'est prêt pour ça
elle est l'incarnation même du
terrorisme high tech
il y a des milliers de voitures dans
cette ville et là elle me disent tout
maintenant je sais ce que ressentent les
flics qui nous prennent en chasse
alfred
on s'accroche
londres
abu dhabi
cuba nos chemins se sont déjà croisés
d'hommes
sans que tu te rendes compte je crois
qu'il est temps de rappeler pourquoi tu
as choisi d'être ici j'ai pas eu le
choix
pour rattraper d'hommes vous aurez
besoin d'un petit coup de main il peut
me dire pourquoi tu fais venir ce buveur
de thé avec sa tête de crapule élevé au
pudding je crois que ces tee shirt trop
moulant ça empêche le sang d'aller au
cerveau tu te remets une taille au
dessus vous deux vous allez bosser
ensemble
génial
[Musique]
depuis le temps que j'attends ça on a un
tank
hier mon tour yoga a pas
ils ne lâchent jamais la faire
je croyais que ce serait un combat de
rue
j'adore ce fait torpillé tiendront lors
quoi
des singles et trop stylées sur ce coup
là oui
je ne sais pas pourquoi tu fais ça mais
je sais une chose c'est que tu m'aimes
ça
ouais ouais les gars
[Musique]